[Music]
how fresh is fresh at morning West Farms
fresh means selling you premium lettuce
that still has its roots packed in soil
why because plants are living organisms
which means the freshest lettuce is live
lettuce honey is this that lettuce from
morning West Farms it sure is dig in
guys M so good good mom
wow this is the freshest lettuce I've
ever had well I bought it when it was
still
alive oh dear God oh God Mom you're the
best oh sweet Jesus no oh God no no no
and it's not just our lettuce all
morning West Farm's fruits and
vegetables are guaranteed to be the
freshest you've ever tasted oh
oh
please
please and we think that when
ingredients are fresh cooking becomes
one of life's greatest pleasures and one
the whole family can
[Applause]
enjoy what are you doing you sick son
of oh God they're taking me Sheila my
love they're taking me Harold no baby
no I'm okay she it's going to be okay
who wants Shortcake
what morning West Farms the freshest
fruits and vegetables you've ever
had hey you this is for my
[Music]
friends